[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 11
avril
vincent voyage pour peindre la lumière
l'artiste versailles et se laisse porter
par la météo depuis de longues années
il propose aujourd'hui une rétrospective
à découvrir au carré à la farine de
versailles ils vivent les commémorations
du conflit 14-18 de l'intérieur 700
élèves de l'enseignement catholique des
yvelines participe à près de cinq ans
projets qui aboutissent
un ouvrage une exposition et des
spectacles inédits ils seront avec nous
pourrons parler et un programme adapté
aux plus petits aux clayes-sous-bois il
ya des trésors plein les poches
à découvrir marine pool vous donnera
rendez-vous des paysages des quatre
coins du monde vincent pose son chevalet
depuis des années au gré de ses voyages
à 80 ans il a ressenti le besoin de
faire le point il expose plusieurs de
ses oeuvres au carré à la farine de
versailles regarder
de la douceur brestoise la dureté de
l'hiver russe l'artiste versailles et
vincent vallat houle attire la lumière
des couleurs d intensité qui dirige son
pinceau je voyage pour pas parce avirons
par exemple il ya quelques jours je
regarde la météo et neige et ivan langer
avait neigé à honfleur
je vais diva deux géants fleurs donc on
met tout de suite dans la voiture le
cheval et des toiles et je file à en
fleurs
là-dessus la météo avait changé il
pleuvait la neige avait fondu bon mais
c'est pas grave ce qui est excitant
c'est l'idée de départ
s'il n'a pas abandonné la peinture à
l'huile vincent préfère aujourd'hui
oublier la technique l'émotion et les
sensations font le reste comme disait
monnaie j'ai voulu peindre un paysage
suis revenu j'avais j'avais fait le
paysage avait pas fait un tableau et des
failles rendent ainsi pour faire un
tableau
quarante ans de travail de peinture de
pérégrinations qui ont donné envie à
l'artiste de faire le point penser de
manière thématique cette exposition est
pour vincent l'occasion de faire une
rétrospective de ce l'on retrouve au
milieu de tous ces tableaux maintenant
un petit peu comme on regarde le fil de
sa vie et je me dis tiens ça c'est l
anecdote qui leur revient à un tel
souvenir de ce tableau de souvenirs de
ce pays
efin perçoit que finalement il ne reste
tellement à découvrir encore après
dix-huit mois de pause vincent présent
près de 70 toiles qui donne envie de
voyager un autre tour
[Musique]
le cheval à versailles est une
institution ne serait ce que par la
présence de l'académie équestre créé il
ya 15 ans un engouement qui se perçoit
jusque dans les collections des
bibliothèques de la ville une exposition
s'intéresse actuellement à l'animal dans
l'art et le pouvoir regarder il trône
majestueux à l'entrée de l'exposition
montée par le souverain louis saez le
cheval symbole de pouvoir
l'art et le pouvoir nous semblait
intéressant d'abord à cause de la
proximité du château de versailles entre
en tant que lieu de pouvoir parce que
nous sommes dans la galerie des affaires
étrangères donc en 6 min stern louis 15
qui est un lieu de pouvoir et donc la
représentation en majesté du cheval nous
semblait quelque chose tout à fait
naturel une centaine de pièces inédites
issues des collections royales et
rassembler le cheval est ainsi objet
d'étude de formation et modèles mais
aussi d'éducation comme ce jouet
mécanique du prince impérial daté de
avec près de 40 autres pièces il est
prêté par un collectionneur privé nos
racines sans sur le dos du cheval nous
étions harnacheur scellier la maison a
commencé avec un certain thierry hermès
sont luis filipe en 1837 comme
manufacture de harnacheur scellier et ce
passionné en question est le petit fils
du fondateur d'hermès
emilie maurice hermès qui elle est donc
en 1871
sans faire un contemporain de marcel
proust emile hermès avait constitué
depuis l'adolescence une extraordinaire
réserve d'objets qui racontait
l'histoire qui portait des traces
je vais dire physique sensuelle de toute
la mémoire de l'humanité qui pendant des
millénaires avait marché avec le cheval
du tableau à l'ouvragé en passant par le
célèbre carré le cheval est ici le roi
un souverain toujours apprécié il
travaille depuis le mois de septembre
700 élèves des yvelines et de leur vive
les commémorations de la grande guerre
de l'intérieur un porche un projet porté
par la compagnie l'air de rien et
plusieurs acteurs de ce projet sont avec
nous en plateau
homme de mucha le directeur de la
compagnie guillaume nadeau gilles qui
est lui au lycée notre dame du grand
champ à versailles géraud sabatier gerra
qui est élève au collège sacré-coeur de
versailles là aussi et et m'achèterai du
collège sainte thérèse au minutes
saint-denis bonjour à tous les quatre
déjà ya pas d un des rares dans les
présentations
alors je me tourne vers vous guillaume
ii muhr à la première question comment
on en vient à faire voir retranché qui
est le nom du projet on en vient à faire
voir retranché parce qu'on travaille
avec des établissements depuis longtemps
et que à chaque fois avec ces
établissements monte des projets
pédagogiques et artistiques et pas des
projets juste artistique de complètement
déconnecté de la pédagogie et que cette
année on voulait monter un projet avec
trois structures la compagnie l'air de
rien tirer du cisq est une maison
d'édition et le studio de création qui
s'appelle rouge indigo on voulait monter
un projet assez fort et que étant dans
l'année du centenaire c'était une
occasion rêvée et que surtout c'est un
une thématique qui rentre dans
énormément de discipline et c'est pour
ça que voilà c'est pour ça qu'on est
parti de ce projet là après le choix de
voir trancher c'est que on s'est
énormément attaché aux lettres et on
s'est énormément attaché aux voix qu'on
n'a pas pu qui n'ont pas pu s'exprimer
il ya cent ans et qu'on redonne leur
voix des restos jaune est ce qui permet
en plus d'avoir un projet labellisé par
la mission du sens à une reconnaissance
supplémentaire
alors justement quatre établissements y
en a trois dans les yvelines qui sont
représentés par vous 3 comment s'est
passée la collaboration avec l'air de
rien ou peut-être entre vous c'était une
expérience assez hors du commun c'est la
première fois pour moi en tout cas que
l'expérience quelque chose comme ça donc
tout d'abord on a on a été voir avec nos
professeurs ce qu'on voulait faire
c'était complètement libre à notre choix
en fait ça l'aspect qui est plutôt bien
que cool ça rapport à ça et ensuite on
s'est mis d'accord avec guillaume dumora
et les autres responsables du projet
comment est ce qu'on a et mettez en
place commencent à les rentrer dans le
livre et les expositions et c'est
héréditaire donc bas les expositions
justement parce que c'est l'un des
comptes-rendus peut-être de ce projet
elle était inhérente celles ci on a trop
dans les quatre établissements
ils ont tous participé ou c'est une
exposition différente
alors en fait l'exposition très
simplement elle part du livre le livre
il ya les projets des 700 élèves dans
toutes les disciplines de l'éducation
nationale et on y tient même les
disciplines scientifiques c'est très
important de le dire exactement
et après l'idée c'est que l'exposition
puisse montrer un échantillonnage des
projets de tous les élèves de toutes les
disciplines
voilà et de tous les de tous les
établissements et après cette exposition
en fait elle circule dans les
établissements où elle va être complété
par d'autres projets qui n'ont pas pu
être dans l'exposition originale et
ensuite au mois de novembre
elle sera présente dans les villes dans
les municipalités à la mairie de
versailles à la mairie d'evreux à la
mairie du mesnil evreux qu'est la
commune de leur convoi réparé le projet
jirau comment ça se passe au collège
c'est pendant les courses et en dehors
du temps scolaire commence on le gère
mais on en a eu sur plusieurs matières
senoussi folie's et heures de cours donc
on est je peux la matière sur la
plastique sur le français sur l'histoire
géo on est on a créé des lettres en
français on a créé des bd qui se
retrouve une exposition en lice en arts
plastiques et enfin tout ce groupe sur
sur plusieurs matières et ont créé tous
et à tous nos projets ils vont entrer
soit d'un spectacle soit dans
l'exposition et tous nos projets se
retrouver pratiquement tous en libre
c'est une époque bien sûr que personne
sur ce plateau n'a connu mais comment
vous
ces jeunes vous l'avez vécu est ce que
ça moyen aussi de se rendre compte
j'imagine que c'est dans votre programme
de troisième c'est un moyen aussi
peut-être de mettre les pieds dedans de
se rendre compte qu ont vécu les poilus
et leur famille et moi ben nous oui
parce que on est en train de travailler
sur les émotions en
en faisant de la danse en faisant plein
de deux chorégraphies et du coup on
essaye d'exprimer leur douleur avec nos
visages longs mathieu guillon mais il
est au collège dont on a parlé de
l'exposition il ya aussi un spectacle
pour vous faut vous faites la mise en
scène mais normand 14 ans 18 et le grand
festin vous les avez créés comment ces
spectacles alors le grand festin on a
d'abord créé le grand festin le grand
festin on est partis du postulat que
nous voulions avoir un projet qui était
fort un spectacle fort pour par entrer
dans les choses très calibrée on va dire
ça comme ça
et donc on voulait parler de l'horreur
parce que c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est d'arriver à compas faire
comprendre à ces jeunes quelle est l
horreur sauf que de la manière la
montrer de manière frontale pardon
c'était impossible c'est rond
on fait un blocage par rapport à ça et
donc c'est pour ça que on est parti sur
une fable une fable comme les fables de
la fontaine
alors qu'on est partis sur des animaux
assez repoussant et que deux cette idée
là on tourne une fois pour exprimer
l'horreur du sang de la douleur de la
souffrance
voilà je crois que ça marche plutôt bien
justement avec les jeunes parce que on
utilise un moyen biaisée pour imager
pour pouvoir parler de cette période
on vient de parler de la peur c'est
qu'est ce qui vous a marqué vous c'est
ça sur cette histoire de 14 18 la peur
la douleur peut-être oui c'est ça la
peur la douleur surtout l'échelle à la
casse s'est produit c'était la première
guerre mondiale on a étudié ça
l'histoire pour moi en anglais en
littérature ici et donc on a vu
plusieurs poèmes où on voyait l'état
dans lesquelles les pois lui-même les
soldats anglais allemand même vivaient
dans les tranchées ils étaient combien
en coupé du reste du monde
il avait aucune porte enfin aucune
échappatoire
c'était ça vraiment c'est quelque chose
hors du commun qu on croit parce que
justement là où ça passe par les lettres
et des expositions et mater plus
concernés par la danse où il ya tout
l'aspect si j'ai bien compris des
gueules cassées aussi ça comment le joug
comment
selon semble approprié pour nous aider
on a regardé quelques extraits de films
qui parlait de la première guerre
mondiale et ça nous a aidés sur les
émotions et on s'imagine qu'on est dans
la peau du personnage et après ça va
tout seul
et pour garder une trace de ce projet
donc l expo ludique spectacle mais c'est
presque éphémère il y à un ouvrage qui
est édité avec le projet de 700 élèves
parce qu'il n'y a que 3 il ya 700 copain
avec vous et notamment les
correspondances l'épistolaire ce que
vous disiez ce qui était très important
à l'époque on se rend plus compte
maintenant avec les sms et les mails et
on se glisse dans la peau d'un soldat ou
d'un proche vous étiez kivu
alors moi en ce qu'on a fait dans notre
groupe on a pris une chanson écrite aux
états unis avant leur entrée dans la
première guerre mondiale et on a analysé
donc d'abord les paroles ensuite aussi à
la mélodie donc la composition les
accords etc et aussi les effets que ça a
eu sur le monde entier sur la population
américaine
qu'est ce que c'est ce que sa poussée
des gens plutôt à rentrer ou sortir de
cette guerre pour moi franchement
c'était intéressant de voir comment
l'auteur il met en scène des techniques
musicales pour pousser les gens à
réfléchir d'une façon ou d'une autre
c'est vraiment très complexe et toi
géraud peut-être peut-être de l'autre
côté je ne sais pas nous on écrivait des
lettres et on échangeait par lettre avec
les écoliers des lèvres d'evreux et donc
on était soit en une personne de la
guerre de 14 18 un soldat et on écrivait
à nos proches de l'ariège est donc le
but c'était de voir comment y vivait
sans comment ils racontaient ce qu'ils
vivaient à leurs proches et leurs
proches eux comment ils la récup'et si
le réconfortait que c'était à y voir les
deux penchants des côtes et comment les
les deux côtés vieux la guerre merci à
tous les cadres d'être revenu en plateau
alors pour vivre comme ses élèves le
conflit de la grande guerre le spectacle
sera jouée le 17 mai à saint rémy lès
chevreuse et le 19 juin au théâtre
montansier il ya d'autres datent un peu
plus éloignés et l'ouvragé lui déjà
disponible aux éditions tiré du cices
stéphane bern était ce mercredi à
elancourt dans le cadre de son
partenariat avec le parc france
miniature
l'animateur de télévision prête sa voix
pour présenter douze monuments et
c'était l'occasion pour lui de revenir
sur la sauvegarde du patrimoine français
pour le préserver stéphane bern chargé
de mission par l'état va lancer en
septembre prochain un tirage spécial du
loto et un jeu de grattage
la somme récoltée servira restaurer des
monuments en péril dans les yvelines la
ville à pauline viardot de bougival est
concerné on écoute stéphane bern il
était au micro de nickel et demi d'euros
vous savez sur tous les sites et bien la
majorité sont des sites qui
appartiennent à des collectivités
locales des mets des petites communes
qui n'ont pas les moyens
quand ils ont trois cents habitants de
restaurer un monument qui qui leur coûte
un million et demi par exemple françois
1er le premier a eu cette idée ensuite
l'huile 15 à créer des monuments avec
l'auto patrimoine et bien si le loto
peut permettre de sauver les monuments
que l'auto a permis de construire est
bien j'aurai accompli ma mission
il a photographié les plus grands de la
scène rock française renault richelain à
l'idée après un parcours dans la presse
locale franck strom travail en agence de
presse plusieurs de ces clichés sont
actuellement rassemblés à l'espace
philippe noiret des clayes-sous-bois
jusqu'au 29 avril
un hommage à la chanson française et
elle
engagement des artistes on les écoute il
est au micro de nickel et demi d'euros
c'est la grande leçon que qui m'ont qui
m'ont donné que ce soit
renault que ce soit balavoine que ce
soit gainsbourg ce soit coluche voilà
fait dire c'est des gens qui avec leur
art
on se sont donné les moyens d'essayer à
leur niveau de faire quelque chose pour
les autres passionnés de photographie ce
rendez vous et pour vous le villepreux
images pixels recherche des panoramiques
amateur ou professionnel vous pouvez
envoyer jusqu'à deux clichés jusqu'au 22
avril
la sélection sera soumise au vote des
internautes jusqu'au 22 mai avant d'être
exposé les 16 et 17 juin prochains
des précisions de gilles fait le club
organisateur il ya deux catégories une
catégorie moins de 18 ans une catégorie
plus de 18 ans donc les plus de 18 ans
il ya deux thèmes nature est libre donc
vous choisissez vraiment votre thème et
les moins de 18 ans est libre donc voilà
donc c'est très simple pas la photo
panoramique c'est un style une ça permet
de voir énormément sur une photo
beaucoup de détails il ya des
spécialistes dont il ya des experts
comme christophe gresse un qui va venir
expliquer cette technique entre autres
du 360 y aura des conférences des
échanges et bien sûr avec les
photographes et on poursuit cette fille
de culture avec notre nouvel invité maaf
les passe-droits bonjour alors vous êtes
artiste plasticienne actuellement en
résidence à la commanderie des templiers
de lavilledieu elle en cours et vous
cherchez à entrevoir l'invisible
exactement donc
l'exposition que je prépare à l'issue de
ma résidence ouvre vendredi 13 et avec
une série de nouvelles créations
donc lié
liant l'art et la science comment est ce
qu'on fait voir ce qu'on ne voit pas
alors justement c'était mon grand
questionnement je pense que l'oeil
organes ne suffit pas à voir qu'il n'est
pas l'essentiel
on a toute une clairvoyance qui est
souvent lié au visionnaire donc qui peut
être l'artiste le prophète
le scientifique et je questionne tout ça
qu'est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on voit
vraiment ce qui existe quelle est notre
propre réalité est ce que ma réalité est
celle aussi de l'autre c'est certes un
certain public pourrait voir autre chose
à ce que vous avez voulu absolument
guider c'est est de regrouper en fait
sous forme de cabinet de curiosités des
objets qui parle de magie d'énergie de
liens qui nous unissent dans l'invisible
de faire vivre une expérience
sensorielle et émotionnelle c'est ce que
j'aime en tout cas tenté de faire et de
huy de repartir avec des questionnements
peut-être existentielle mais des
éléments qui nous relient tous je parle
beaucoup dans l'exposition de
l'infiniment grand à l'infiniment petit
de quoi en effet de quoi ce qui nous
relie tous voilà donc c'est un espèce de
fil rouge comme ça qu'on retrouve à
travers à travers les 14 installations
et notamment ce qui m'a passionné grâce
à la résidence art science était un peu
spécifique cette année c'était de
collaborer vraiment avec des
scientifiques et justement des
ingénieurs des chercheurs de l'ue est
une auto lease est mon est exactement le
fab lab de la verrière qui a participé
vraiment une installation nous l'avait
rêvé donc qu'ils ont réalisé et puis les
scientifiques plutôt en sciences
cognitives donc sondé un peu les zones
neuronale qui sont extérieurs pour nous
et essayer de filtrer des données comme
ça et les transcrire en mots en sons
ça prouve un peu ce qui nous a dit avec
nos invités précédent là n'est pas
différencier de la science exactement
moi j'ai toujours souhaité mais ça c'est
depuis le départ aussi de la création
liés l'art et la science parce que je
suis admis admiratrice du travail de
léonard de vinci
qu'il y ait déjà ça à l'époque et je
trouve qu'on a séparés on a mis des
choses dans les cases alors qu'en fait
on a des ponts
évident en fait entre ces deux domaines
donc là c'était un peu poussé nos
limites à chacun on est allé voir du
côté de la science les scientifiques
sont allées du bois du côté de la haie
du coup ça nous a menés à des chemins
qu'on n'aurait pas abordés si nous et
vous avez créé une sorte de cabinet de
curiosités williate de tous notamment
vous avez herbach y sommes il est
question du langage des fleurs parfois
de sorcellerie avec quant à bill c'était
papillon oui tout votre univers
alors il ya beaucoup de nature il ya
beaucoup de 2 oui je parle de magie mais
la benne magie la magie blanche la magie
ancestrale le savoir qu'avec nos
ancêtres de des plantes médicinales la
reliance allait l'une au ciel comment
lire voilà des choses dans le ciel dans
les constellations
donc il ya volage et j'ai fabriqué
vraiment un cabinet de curiosités avec
beaucoup aussi une d'éléments qui parle
de wii 2 de notre être au monde avec
j'espère poésie et humour très j'aime
beaucoup d'humour donc à des petites
touches et chacun fera son petit pas
cours et j'espère voilà aura envie de
revenir parce que je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup d'éléments qu'on peut saisir
différemment en revenant et ont donné
dix huit il est impossible de se passer
du virtuel mon nom vouliez encore ça
comme vous voulez l'explosion ferme du
mousseau un peu moins déprimée moins
l'esprit oui ça faisait ça faisait des
années je travaillais sur du virtuel et
beaucoup de vidéos interactives là
j'avais vraiment envie de revenir à
l'objet et
mais en liant le camp même les
technologies mais plutôt robotique
électronique qui servent à animer de
façon magique des choses donc
effectivement il ya moins de virtuel il
ya voilà il y a quand même cette
présence là mais réel et virtuel se
mêlent et pour brouiller un petit peu
l'essence en fait mais on n'est plus
dans la poésie concrète et autour de
cette exposition il ya des ateliers vous
allez changer alors les attendions
commencé en janvier puisque je suis en
résidence depuis octobre avec deux
classes élémentaires et deux classes de
collège de trappes en section
aménagèrent plastique
pareil sur la thématique de l'aï trompé
l'oeil augmenté le défi était de relier
aussi l'art et la science et la
restitution des travaux des élèves
seront montrés demi mais à la fin
d'exposition avec cette volonté ce désir
d'intégrer tous ces travaux dans mon
exposition aussi parce que je trouve que
c'était un travail aussi qui m'a
beaucoup nourri on s'est nourri les uns
les autres je trouvais ça juste qu'ils
aient leur place aussi là pour qu'on
voie ce que faveur mersen man show est
pas d avoir répondu à notre invitation
alors pour vous aussi entre voir
l'invisible
l'exposition à la commanderie des
templiers de lavilledieu c'est jusqu'au
1er juillet donc y'a large plage pour
aller la voir et je vous propose
maintenant d'ouvrir une page cinéma
[Musique]
les tout petits sont à l'honneur de
notre coup de coeur cinéma de cette
semaine écoutez marilyn coup de l'espace
philippe noiret des clayes-sous-bois
bonjour le coup de coeur de l'espace
philippe noiret cette semaine c'est dans
le cadre de la saison jeune public
donc j'en profite pour vous rappeler
qu'on est une saison jeune public avec
des films des cinés goûters et des
spectacles programmés à l'année cette
semaine on a le programme des trésors
pierre ma poche qui est un joli
programme d'animations pour les enfants
et les plus grands à partir de 3 ans
donc c'est un programme avec 6,6 petits
films qui ont été réalisés par six
réalisatrice talentueuse et donc c'est
des histoires dans très de solidarité
avec de jolies rencontres par exemple la
rencontre d'une baleine et d'un nuage
d'une petite fille et d'un dragon avec
des techniques d'animation très variés
que ce soit de l'aquarelle
du papier découpé par exemple ou encore
du pastel et c'est un programme qui fait
la part belle à la musique
donc voilà c'est l'occasion d'initier
les plus jeunes pour une première séance
de cinéma par exemple et pour voir de
jolis films d'animation très poétique
donc je rappelle que dans le cadre de la
saison jeune public
on fait aussi des ateliers et des
goûters donc n'hésitez pas à vous
trouverez ça dans la plaquette de notre
saison culturelle
[Musique]
avant de nous quitter quelques
rendez-vous la batterie de guyancourt
lance un appel aux musiciens pour la
fête de la musique 2018 cette année elle
se tiendra le samedi 23 juin et si vous
êtes intéressé la batterie attend vos
bio lien vidéo et supports audio à
maurepas florent favier oscar claque
vous clark que vous embarque pour une
ode à la liberté
un voyage poétique et rock'n'roll un
extrait de la bande annonce
[Musique]
il
e
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce set une culture merci
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
mercredi prochain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]